[Música]
hola les damos la bienvenida a enlace
centroamérica desde costa rica 25
candidatos a la presidencia se han
presentado a las elecciones generales
del 6 de febrero una cifra récord en la
historia de costa rica calificada como
una de las democracias más sólidas de
américa latina' les contaremos sobre el
posible retorno al poder de dos de los
partidos tradicionales los
costarricenses también elegirán entre
decenas de candidatos de 38 partidos a
los 57 representantes de la asamblea
legislativa que deberán resolver las
demandas de la sociedad costarricense la
más importante la reactivación económica
atender el déficit fiscal y el desempleo
recortar el gasto público combatir la
corrupción gestionar la pandemia
modernizar el sector eléctrico y de
transporte mejorar la educación son los
asuntos más urgentes de resolver
tras dos años de pandemia la ciudadanía
debate sobre cómo se debe manejar la
emergencia sanitaria xi con medidas
restrictivas para detener contagios y
muertes o con un manejo más relajado que
prioriza la economía que ha sido
fuertemente afectada por los cierres de
fronteras de negocios y de actividades
sociales sin duda seguimos teniendo un
desempleo alto y un crecimiento
económico para decirlo de alguna manera
tímido entonces este es un tema que
también está en la campaña el estallido
de al menos cuatro escándalos de
corrupción recientes como el caso
llamado cochinilla que involucró a
empresas de construcción e instituciones
del gobierno y otros que han salpicado
distintos poderes del estado ha hecho
que se posicione en la agenda la lucha
contra la corrupción
es un tema que canaliza un malestar que
tiene un sector importante de la
población y básicamente hay varios
candidatos que incluso utilizan una
retórica populista para tratar de
capitalizar este tipo de sentimientos y
también de posiciones en este 2022
existe la posibilidad de retorno al
poder de uno
tradicionales liberación nacional o
unidad social cristiana
josé maría figueres ex presidente de la
república e hijo del presidente que
abolió el ejército señalado de estar
involucrado en un escándalo de
corrupción en el pasado es el candidato
de liberación de centroderecha por la
unidad social cristiana también de
centroderecha la candidata es lynette
saborío ex vicepresidenta de la
república ambos aspirantes se encuentran
en los primeros lugares de preferencia
en las encuestas aunque todo indica que
ningún candidato obtendría el triunfo en
una primera vuelta
no se descarta una segunda ronda en la
que participe alguno de los aspirantes
de partidos nuevos ubicados entre el
tercer y quinto lugar en intención de
votos como fabricio alvarado periodista
y pastor
rodrigo chávez ex funcionario del banco
mundial sancionado por esa entidad por
un patrón de comportamiento inapropiado
no deseado y josé maría villalta actual
diputado por el frente amplio de
izquierda y el mandato de carlos
alvarado actual presidente es el segundo
consecutivo del partido acción ciudadana
1 que irrumpió como alternativa al
tradicional bipartidismo en 2014
socialdemócrata y progresista y que
según las encuestas no tendría un tercer
mandato seguido algo que nunca ha
logrado un partido en el país
más del 40% de la población se
encontraba indecisa sobre por quién
votar a mediados de enero pero a medida
que se acerca el día los votantes van
definiendo se una parte importante del
electorado se decide en las urnas por lo
que la volatilidad es la principal
característica del panorama electoral
costarricense aseguran los especialistas
la mayoría pues consideró que son de
relleno y hay dos preponderantes
obviamente la
la población en general se está
decantando por el tradicionalismo en uno
y pues el cambio en el otro tampoco
difícil
estamos muy indecisos por quién votar
porque eso está muy duro la situación no
se ve muy bien votar por chávez creo que
es una persona que
y creo pienso que vendría a acomodar un
poco la parte económica que es lo que
ahora está un poquito más golpeado ahora
por toda la cuestión fiscal y demás si
bien las propuestas de soluciones a los
problemas que aquejan al país caldean el
debate público hay un tema sobre el que
existe consenso casi absoluto y es la
importancia de invertir en la salud
los costarricenses se sienten orgullosos
del robusto sistema de salud público con
cobertura casi universal
priorizar la salud podría ser una razón
por la que los costarricenses viven más
con una esperanza de vida de más de 78
años una de las más altas de américa
latina' en costa rica se halla la
península de nicoya una de 10 zonas
azules del mundo llamadas así por la
longevidad de su población superior a
los noventa y cien años estudios apuntan
a que una alimentación y hábitos
saludables la unión familiar y una
sólida espiritualidad son parte del
secreto de una larga vida
hasta aquí con este enlace centroamérica
sobre costa rica gracias por habernos
acompañado para ver nuestros programas
sigan los en france24 en france 24 punto
com